the reason why we can't just cancel say
this day in this day right it's because
that day is actually operating on
something right in the same way that you
can't cancel right I can't cancel the
science right and say oh it's just
excellent 30 degrees
that sign is inextricably linked to the
X and that's why I kind of said look you
have D on DX but it doesn't really it
can't really hang on its own it has to
be something there right it operates on
something and it's the same with this
one right so excuse me this D is really
attached to this Y the d squared is
attached to the Y right so just like I
can't give it bamm-bamm right because
it's like that would be meaningless
that's really that's really a whole
there's a whole thing okay so therefore
yeah that's why the DS no simpler - okay
so why why not this is that what you're
asking
yeah experimentation is a lazy that's
what it really should be honestly that's
what it really should be because
otherwise you know wait if I say this
right it really isn't clear whether I
mean this or this right
in fact honestly if I if I saw that and
I didn't know that this convention has
been used I would assume this that's
what I miss you okay but this convention
is just so completely taken over and
math minions are so averse to writing
this brackets because it looks so much I
still like that they just say it well
everyone knows what we're talking about
right and so they kind of cheated
in an exam what it says is that negative
of x squared or negative x whole things
when you see this yeah yeah okay now
this is a perfect example of why
actually DX squared just by itself is
not a good notation because when I see
this right what I'm saying is the X gets
squared first and then you slap a minus
sign on the front had I wanted the
negative 2b squared as well I would have
put the negative in there and then
square okay
correct now this is a very special case
in like I said it's a bit awkward I kind
of wish they hadn't done it like this
because these are the two different
rules I hate that when you have two
different
that's what mathematics is supposed to
be about that you have a consistent set
of rules I suppose however I'll let this
one pass because number one it just gets
you so much right that in this field
it's like well there's no ambiguity
really people I'm not differentiating
with yet regard to x squared you can but
that's just weird all right
and secondly it sort of fits in this
category I was talking outside and that
kind of thing we all know what this
means right except why do we use that
notation when what we really mean is
this the sign is not getting squared at
all it's the whole thing
you can't just square the sign well it's
used so frequently we're kind of happy
to just introduce this kind of like
slightly read notation because we're all
comfortable with use of you okay so it's
sort of a concession to convenience in
some ways okay any questions on them
yeah no there's really creepy doing
table though in some ways I mean we
don't really need to do anything because
the only things really is you're just
differentiating again that's all you're
doing
did you want an integer because then
you're squaring this side good it's like
what it looks like with a d squared why
it looks like that you're not squaring
the whole thing why correct that's
exactly right so that's why it's like
you know that is not helpful and make
notations and just wait until we get to
motion and I have yet another way of
describing each of these but I guess
what happens is it's a bit like language
it's a
the word likes a gentleman right the
word gentleman used to actually have a
meaning it used to mean that you were a
person who had earned a certain amount
of real estate like an actual number
like I don't know some number a keys and
you your house had a code of items
that's what it meant right but then it's
sort of started saying oh well people
who are gentlemen they cut it act in a
certain way because they're kind of
quite respectable and like because of
all I'm gonna have education and so on
so then it's time to become young like
are you acting like a gentleman it's
like yeah I have the land I have the
kind of moms but I'm a bit of a jerk so
say you're not a gentleman right and
then as that sort of way of language
kind of cruise the what judgment has the
meaning now right it's it's like I say
gentleman to anyone right it's kind of
like is like which kind of just
transforms and does that though it is
worth saying like all of this notation
for derivatives right um Isaac Newton is
a widely regarded as like the founder of
calculus he wasn't um do you remember I
told you about another guy right he
started with an L Leiden it's right now
lion it's likeit's is not the famous guy
because Isaac Newton is famous for
everything right but wideness is
notation is the one that we use because
it was it's better it's objectively
better right you can do better
mathematics with kids than with Newton's
right so kind of even though sometimes
you get these awkward consistent the
wonderful thing about a collective
endeavor is that the best language tends
to win even if it's slightly
inconsistent okay really really quickly
an example the quite trivial
okay this is so simple right this is so
silly because in a sense at least at the
moment right the only thing you need to
get to the second derivative is just
just just go again just differentiate
again and you are very good
differentiated right so this by the way
accents why I keep on saying you know
you've got to say what you're talking
about like I'm gonna do the first
derivative and I've got to say I'm
working out the first tribute now and
I'm going to use notation that indicates
that rather just saying equals and start
doing things okay so that's really
what's gonna happen that's it done that
was not complicated right I've worked
out the first derivative and then I just
differentiate again right which in this
case is okay great so like I said
nothing to it question right what does
this have to do with this that's an open
question I'm just going to leave for you
to think about or to point out as well
that the degree as we're working with
polynomials the degree as you go down
each derivative it just drops by one you
notice that because that's what happens
when you run when you went from four to
three and then three to okay so each
subsequent derivative at least when
you're dealing with polynomials will
have a will be a lower order polynomial
will have a smaller degree by one